o, mejor aún, podemos oír decir algunas cosas
que las mujeres a menudo no pueden oírse diciendo.
Ahora, comprendo que es un problema, es el sexismo.
Pero es la verdad. Y así una de las cosas que digo a los hombres,
y mis colegas y siempre digo,
es que necesitamos a más hombres que tengan el coraje y la fuerza
de comenzar a levantarse y decir algunas de estas cosas,
y estar con las mujeres y no contra ellas
y fingir que de alguna manera esta es
una batalla entre los sexos y otras clases de absurdos.
Vivimos en el mundo juntos.
Y por cierto, una de las cosas que realmente me molesta
sobre la retórica contra las feministas y otros
que han construido para mujeres maltratadas
y movimientos de crisis de violación del mundo
es de alguna manera, como dije antes, que son anti-hombres.
¿Qué pasa con todos los muchachos que están profundamente afectados
de manera negativa por lo que un hombre adulto les está haciendo
contra sus madres, ellos mismos, sus hermanas?
¿Qué pasa con todos esos chicos?
¿Qué pasa con todos los niños y los jóvenes
que han sido traumatizados por la violencia de los hombres adultos?
¿Sabes qué? El mismo sistema que produce
los hombres que abusan de las mujeres produce hombres que maltraten a otros hombres.
Y si queremos hablar de víctimas masculinas,
hablemos de víctimas masculinas.
La mayoría de las víctimas masculinas de la violencia son víctimas de la violencia de otros hombres.
Así que eso es algo que tienen en común las mujeres y los hombres.
Somos ambos víctimas de la violencia de los hombres.
Así que es en nuestro propio interés directo,
sin dejar de mencionar el hecho de que la mayoría de los hombres que conozco
tienen mujeres y las niñas por las que nos preocupamos profundamente,
en nuestras familias y nuestros círculos de amistad y en todos los sentidos.
Por eso hay tantas razones por las que necesitamos que los hombres hablen.
Parece obvio decirlo en voz alta. ¿No es cierto?
Ahora, la naturaleza del trabajo que hago y mis colegas
en la cultura deportiva y el ejército estadounidense, en las escuelas,
somos pioneros en este enfoque llamado del espectador
para la prevención de la violencia de género.
Y quiero darle lo más destacado del enfoque del espectador,
porque es un gran cambio de temática,
aunque hay un montón de detalles,
pero el meollo de esto es que en lugar de ver a los hombres como perpetradores
y a las mujeres como víctimas,
o a las mujeres como perpetradoras, los hombres como víctimas,
o cualquier combinación que haya.
Estoy usando el género binario. Sé que hay más
que hombres y mujeres, hay más que hombres y mujeres.
Y hay mujeres que son culpables,
y por supuesto, hay hombres que son víctimas.
Hay un espectro entero.
Pero en lugar de verlo en la manera binaria
nos centramos en todos nosotros como lo que llamamos espectadores,
y un espectador se define como alguien que no es
un agresor o una víctima en una situación dada,
así que en otras palabras, amigos, compañeros, colegas,
compañeros de trabajo, miembros de la familia,
aquellos que no están directamente involucrados en la díada de abuso,
pero que estamos incrustados en relaciones sociales, familiares,
laborales, escolares y con otros semejantes
que podrían estar en esa situación. ¿Qué hacemos?
¿Cómo hablamos sin temor? ¿Cómo desafiamos a nuestros amigos?
¿Cómo apoyamos a nuestros amigos? Pero ¿cómo no
permanecer en silencio ante el abuso?
Ahora, cuando se trata de hombres y la cultura masculina,
el objetivo es conseguir a los hombres que no son abusivos
para desafiar a los hombres que sí lo son.
Y cuando digo abusivos, no me refiero solo
a hombres que le están pegando a las mujeres.
No solo estamos diciendo a un hombre cuyo amigo
está abusando de su novia que deben detener al chico
en el momento del ataque.
Es una forma ingenua de crear un cambio social.
Es a lo largo de un continuo, estamos tratando de conseguir hombres
que se interrumpan mutuamente.
Así, por ejemplo, si eres un chico y estás en un grupo de chicos
jugando al póker, hablando, pasando el rato, sin ninguna mujer presente,
y otro hombre dice algo sexista o degradante
o de acoso a las mujeres,
en lugar de risa o fingir que no oyes
necesitamos hombres que digan, "Eh, eso no es gracioso.
Sabes, podría ser mi hermana de la que está hablando,
y podrías bromear sobre otra cosa?
O ¿podría hablar de otra cosa?
No valoro ese tipo de conversación".
Al igual que si eres una persona blanca y otra persona blanca
hace un comentario racista, y esperan, espero,
que la gente blanca interrumpa esa promulgación racista
de un compañero blanco.
Al igual que con el heterosexismo, si eres una persona heterosexual
y no adoptas comportamientos de acoso o abusos
hacia las personas de diversas orientaciones sexuales,
si no dices algo frente a otras personas heterosexuales haciendo eso,
entonces, en cierto sentido, ¿no es tu silencio
una forma de consentimiento y complicidad?
Bien, el enfoque del espectador está tratar de darles herramientas
para interrumpir ese proceso y hablar sin temor
y crear un clima de cultura de pares
donde se vea el comportamiento abusivo como inaceptable,
no solo porque es ilegal, sino porque está mal
y es inaceptable en la cultura de pares.
Y si conseguimos que los hombres
que actúen de manera sexista pierdan estatus,
los hombres jóvenes y muchachos que actúan sexistamente
y acosando a niñas y mujeres,
así como a otros niños y hombres,
pierdan estatus como resultado de eso, ¿adivinen qué?
Vamos a ver una disminución radical del abuso.
Porque el perpetrador típico no está enfermo y torcido,
es un chico normal en todos los sentidos. ¿No?
Ahora, entre las muchas cosas buenas que Martin Luther King
dijo en su corta vida fue,
"Al final, lo que perjudicará más
no son las palabras de nuestros enemigos
sino el silencio de nuestros amigos".
Al final, lo que perjudicará a la mayoría no son las palabras
de nuestros enemigos sino el silencio de nuestros amigos.
Ha habido un montón de silencio en la cultura masculina
sobre esta tragedia en curso de violencia de los hombres
contra las mujeres y los niños, ¿no es así?
Ha habido un montón de silencio.
Y todo lo que estoy diciendo es que tenemos que romper ese silencio,
y necesitamos más hombres para hacerlo.
Ahora, es más fácil decirlo que hacerlo,
porque lo estoy diciendo ahora, pero les digo que no es fácil
en la cultura masculina desafiarse unos a otros,
que es una de las razones por las cuales
parte del cambio de paradigma que tiene que pasar
es no solo entender estos temas como asuntos de los hombres,
sino también son cuestiones de liderazgo para los hombres.
Porque en última instancia, la responsabilidad de adoptar una postura
sobre estos temas no debe caer sobre los hombros
de niños o adolescentes en la escuela secundaria
o los hombres universitarios. Debe estar en los hombres adultos con poder.
Los hombres adultos con poder son los que necesitamos para responsabilizarse
de ser líderes en la materia,
porque cuando alguien habla en una cultura de pares
y desafía e interrumpe, él o ella
está siendo líder, ¿verdad, correcto?
Pero en una escala grande, necesitamos más hombres adultos con poder
para comenzar a dar prioridad a estas cuestiones,
y no hemos visto aún, ¿los hay?
Estaba en una cena hace varios años atrás,
y trabajo ampliamente con el ejército estadounidense, todos los servicios.
Y estaba en la cena y esta mujer me dijo
—creo que pensó que ella era un poco inteligente— dijo,
"Así que ¿hace cuánto tiempo que has estado haciendo entrenamiento de sensibilidad
con los marines?"
Y yo dije, "Con todo respeto,
no hago entrenamiento de sensibilidad con los marines.
Doy un programa de liderazgo en el cuerpo de marines."
Ahora, sé que es un poco pomposa, mi respuesta,
pero es una distinción importante, porque no creo
que lo que necesitamos es la formación de la sensibilidad.
Necesitamos entrenamiento en liderazgo, porque, por ejemplo,
cuando un entrenador profesional o un directivo de un equipo de béisbol
o de fútbol —y trabajo extensamente en esta esfera también—
hace un comentario sexista, hace una afirmación homofóbica,
hace un comentario racista, habrá discusiones
en los blogs de deportes y en programas radiales de deportes.
Y algunas personas dirán, "Necesitaba capacitación en sensibilidad".
Y otros dirán, "Olvídalo.
Sabes, es de ser políticamente correcto es para enloquecerse,
hizo una declaración estúpida. Déjalo pasar".
Mi argumento es que él no necesita entrenamiento de sensibilidad.
Necesita entrenamiento en liderazgo,
porque está siendo un mal líder, porque en una sociedad
con diversidad de género y diversidad sexual
(aplausos)
y diversidad racial y étnica, al hacer
ese tipo de comentarios, estás fallando en tu liderazgo.
Si podemos hacer este punto que estoy haciendo
a poderosos hombres y mujeres en nuestra sociedad
en todos los niveles de autoridad y poder,
va a cambiar, va a cambiar
el paradigma del pensamiento de la gente.
Saben, por ejemplo, que yo trabajo mucho
en atletismo universitario a lo largo de Norte América.
Sabemos mucho sobre cómo prevenir
violencia doméstica y sexual, ¿bien?
No hay ninguna excusa para una universidad
no tenga formación de prevención de violencia doméstica y sexual
ordenada a todos los estudiantes atletas, entrenadores, administradores,
como parte de su proceso educativo.
Sabemos lo suficiente para saber que fácilmente podemos hacer eso.
¿Pero saben lo que falta? El liderazgo.
Pero no es el liderazgo de los estudiantes atletas.
El liderazgo del director deportivo,
del presidente de la Universidad, de las personas a cargo
que toman decisiones sobre recursos
y que toman decisiones sobre las prioridades en la configuración institucional.
Es una falla, en la mayoría de los casos, de liderazgo de los hombres.
Vean Penn State. Penn State es la madre
de momentos que enseñan sobre el enfoque del espectador.
Tenía tantas situaciones en ese asunto
donde los hombres en posiciones de gran alcance no actuaron
para proteger a los niños, en este caso, muchachos.
Es increíble, realmente. Pero cuando te adentras en él,
te das cuenta de que hay presiones de los hombres.
Hay restricciones dentro de las culturas entre los hombres,
razón por la cual tenemos que animar a los hombres
a romper esas presiones.
Y una de las maneras de hacerlo es decir
que hay un montón de hombres que se preocupan profundamente por estas cuestiones.
Sé esto. Trabajo con hombres,
y he estado trabajando con decenas de miles,
cientos de miles de hombres desde hace muchas décadas.
Da miedo, cuando lo piensas bien, cuántos años.
Pero hay muchos hombres que se preocupan profundamente por estas cuestiones,
pero preocuparse profundamente no es suficiente.
Necesitamos a más hombres con las agallas,
con el coraje, con la fuerza, con la integridad moral
de romper nuestro silencio cómplice y desafiarse unos a otros
y estar con las mujeres y no contra ellas.
Por cierto, se lo debemos a las mujeres.
No hay ninguna duda sobre ello.
Pero también se lo debemos a nuestros hijos.
También se lo debemos a los hombres jóvenes que están creciendo
por todo el mundo en situaciones donde no eligen
ser un hombre en una cultura que les dice
que la virilidad es una cierta manera.
No hacen la elección.
Nosotros que tenemos opción tenemos la oportunidad
y una responsabilidad para ellos también.
Espero que, de ahora en adelante, hombres y mujeres,
trabajen juntos, puede comenzar el cambio
y la transformación que va a pasar
para que las generaciones futuras no tengan el nivel de tragedia
del que nos ocupamos a diario.
Sé que podemos hacerlo. Podemos hacerlo mejor.
Muchas gracias. (Aplausos)